[Music]
[Applause]
is that what you were looking for the
intro the intro music it wasn't just
music it wasn't just me mj was asking
for it too where's the cute music yeah
so here's the problem the last few weeks
i play it at the end
i play it at the end but i haven't been
playing it at the beginning because
there's you know there's software here
there's transitions right right right
you know and so we're trying to no i get
it you know being uh
the host and the you know running the
production i mean i was doing when i
when we were interviewing matt the other
day when he came down to talk about yeah
you ran the board yeah ran the board
it's hard like to
to be running the board but then also
being aware to be like oh okay i'm
listening and i also have this question
and right so i got it for a while for a
while i just like sat there and i was
like okay i got to make sure the
transition's right i don't have a little
so i'm doing it all for my mouse which
is like right two two clicks you know
right well i sit and i listen i have to
look at twitter i have to pay attention
to the dms with the breaking news yeah
there's a lot of stuff going on over
here this is just not me yelling and
screaming into them right we need to get
it really
yeah yeah i could i could put one in the
back over here you know like
yeah yeah this is and also somebody
asked me earlier if this is a green
screen this is not a green screen this
is just right well maybe it is i don't
know yeah it could be it's a peter
navarro type green screen that um
gabe's involved in now now you do use
what does it say
peter navarro
laugh laugh out loud yeah lots of love i
mean laugh out loud
did you see the hearings yesterday
because we have a couple of these
boneheads um
mainly louie gohmert and jim jordan that
were
on the list yesterday of course we know
why peter navarro is is on the list
today yeah yeah um you know yesterday
the news broke that he was possibly
going to be indicted and there was a
grand jury but and louis gomer and jim
jordan were in this hearing yesterday
did you catch some of this these this
footage
yeah did you see the you know what's the
funny video i don't yes yes because we
played it but we can play it again i
just think what is funny is that
the three people
that were there it was or at least the
three people that i saw on the panel in
person were jim jordan louis gomer in uh
thomas massey right right right that's
the only republicans that's what you're
right
all the other chairs were [ __ ] empty
eric swalwell is taught which was funny
because it was like yes everyone you
know uh who was done remotely on the
republican side were you know other
computers or whatever but it was just
funny to see those three people who are
complete [ __ ] idiots
who don't care anything about actual
uh well-being of people who have uh you
know
dealt with um you know
child
uh
not trafficking but you know
well again jim i don't report sex crimes
sitting over there eric swalwell is
giving the speech and here here it is
here um and i'm gonna bring it up big so
everyone can see it while he's talking
and you can watch you can watch
uh jim jordan completely ignored the
most important thing that eric swallow
was trying to say during this hearing is
right
hey these kids were slaughtered dummy
like he's trying to make the point that
children are being slaughtered and jim
jordan's just like ah what are we having
for lunch am i ordering a sandwich yeah
or am i ordering look away while people
are being molested in the shower i'm not
sure which one i'm ordering but uh one
of those will be great for lunch i mean
literally that that that's the
the bonehead in this here so
watch because jim jordan really didn't i
mean i'm sure he said a lot of [ __ ] to
be boneheaded this week yeah but it was
his well he also said dumb [ __ ] about
the gas prices he kept tweeting about
gas prices this week
he was like
but he also voted against right
the price gouging right so so watch as
jim jordan
his boneheadedness is his nothingness in
this clip watch
watch the clip 19 kids are dead
19 children are dead and so to my
republican colleagues i ask
who are you here for
are you here for our kids
or are you here for the killers
because if you were here for the kids
you would do all you could to protect
the next
school shooting that's about to happen
and we know what's going to happen in
america
you would vote to raise the age on
purchasing an assault rifle you would
vote to ban high-capacity magazines you
would vote to require safe storage and
you would vote to address ghost guns
which are ravaging communities across
america but if you're here for the
killers
you would do everything to make it
easier for the next school shooting to
happen and mr jordan to say we are
trying to dramatically change the
country dramatically change the country
if trying to make sure that no more kids
are put in the ground with a superman
coffin means dramatically change the
country
guilty
that's why we're here kids are going in
the ground today and you call that
trying to dramatically change the
country
why aren't you trying to dramatically
change the number of dead kids going
into the ground mr jordan
who are you here for the kids or the
killers
my republican colleagues are here for
carnival games
they say it's about mental health okay
we try and fund mental health they vote
against it
they say and you you've seen jim jordan
there not paying attention to
now eric swallow is actually going to go
into their arguments here which is the
arguments that they make and again we've
been saying that they're [ __ ]
because they are because
they they
there might be an argument for people in
this country receiving mental health
what that has to do with guns i have no
idea but
because people have mental health
problems regardless if they have access
to a weapon or not and that's why
republicans do not want to do [ __ ] about
mental health because it has nothing to
do with
keeping good access and ready to access
at weapons of war that's why they don't
want to do anything about mental health
right we say it's about schools we try
and fund the schools fund the teachers
they vote against it they say it's about
policing
300 million dollars in the american
rescue plan for community policing they
all voted against it and they don't want
to listen to the police if they listen
to the police they'd listen to the major
city's chiefs who have called for
background checks red flag laws banning
bum stocks and banning high-capacity
magazines
talk about back the blue right
yep i mean it's always always with this
back to blue nonsense and then when it
comes to actually backing the blue and
taking their stance now nope can't do
that because louie gomer and i'm not
going to play that clip but he gets on
this big
[ __ ] thing about big cities and all
this nonsense um and about how it's the
big cities and he doesn't understand
that the [ __ ] guns that are in the
big cities aren't bought in the big
cities you knuckle dragger yeah they're
bought in the states where you are
taking away
the the
the
backstops of people who don't need to
get guns to get guns and that's why lure
gilmore's on the list but let's continue
here
my favorite
it's about the family we need to address
the family issues in america we don't
want to help feed a family we're going
to make it harder for kids to live on
food stamps we don't want to help a
family learn we're going to go after
teachers in america we don't want to
help kids go to college we don't want to
give them jobs we're going to vote
against the infrastructure and jobs bill
and then they say that laws don't work
but they have no problem crafting laws
to take away a woman's right to make her
own health care decision that law must
work
they have no problem going after laws to
ban drugs
there's plenty of laws on the books to
ban drugs but no it's all about the
person laws don't work when you have
evil in our country that's what they
tell us
and then they tell us that we're in a
country where you have violent video
games mental health problems schools
that can't be secured and too many
gun-free zones and their solution to
that is to put more of the most
dangerous weapons into that mix
that's insane
they're also out of touch with the
overwhelming majority of gun owners in
america an organization called 97
percent
just put out a poll that said among gun
owners and they only polled gun owners
86 percent support background checks
76 percent support safe storage
67
support red flag laws those are gun
owners so who are you here for our kids
or the killers
i'm here for people like alex navarro
she's a moms demand action leader in the
san francisco bay area
and last week after i convened a meeting
among my constituents and people like
fred guttenberg and dr joe saccharon an
emergency room physician
at johns hopkins
alex navarro told my constituents
that her six-year-old daughter
after uvalde
after seeing the images behind me
said to her
mom
what picture are you going to use for me
jesus [ __ ] christ like this moment
when you realize that your children
are like when am when am i going to be a
victim when is this going to happen to
me like they're in the realization that
even when the children even when the
[ __ ] children in this country realize
that there is an issue and that they're
next but the republicans are like oh we
need to we need to have better locks we
need to we need to put these kids in
prison
and the kids are like well that ain't
going to stop it even they know it's not
going to i mean we've we've i mean you
know we have sadly come to a point in
our country and ours our
our society
that the fact that a child
who should be you know a young child out
it should be outside you know scraping
their knees getting dirt on themselves
like running around playing ball
whatever it is
they should be having fun right
the fact that we have to like they're
having this like existential moment
because they have to realize
that their lives are at risk and that at
any point some crazy [ __ ] person or
not crazy decides to take a gun under
some belief and go shoot them
just for living just for [ __ ]
existing
meanwhile they like i said they should
be out having fun
and now we have children like this is
something that you would be like
you know not
having to consider you know the
mortality
of life like
that that you should be having until
you're way older right it's like oh i
gotta figure out my 401k and my
retirement plan i got these savings and
how am i going to file my taxes like
this is a a topic that you should not be
thinking about until later on in life
you know not when you're a kid when
you're like you know less than 10
thinking
well i've had a good life so far i
wonder
how i'm going to be buried right am i
going to be cremated or am i going to go
and like eric sawwell says like am i
going to superman coffin like that that
that type of ques that type of logic and
that type of reasoning and that type of
just thinking
should not
happen that should not exist for
children
like talk about putting children in a
incredibly stressful environment holy
[ __ ] right out of the womb they're
already thinking okay so what color do
you guys want when you're buried like
what the [ __ ] it's it's it's insane and
and
to demean children as well be like oh
you can't read this book and you can't
learn math but you must go to a prison
you must go to a prison every single day
because we're not willing we're not
willing to let a handful of companies
lose their profits in this country a
handful of
families a handful of families in this
country not lose their profits because
we just can't sacrifice your safety for
common sense laws that would take money
out of their pockets this is nonsense
now watch here
uh as eric's well what wraps it up
what picture are you going to use for me
that's what children are asking their
parents across america because they
don't believe
they're going to come out alive what
picture are you going to use for me
we're supposed to be the protectors
we're supposed to be here for the kids
and so to my colleagues today who
flew in town
came to
work got ready to argue my question is
why did you come here for at all why did
you come here at all
if you're not here for the children
why don't you go to the funeral of the
killer because that's the only place
where the killer is being celebrated
we're here to get things done and
protect our kids what's your job
i yield back
and of course um
there isn't anyone really that he's
talking to if you look at the uh
let's see if i can find that back now
here is here's here's why jim jordan
was on the bonehead of the week you see
him here ordering food or whatever he's
doing i'm not really i'm not really sure
what he's doing he's probably he's
probably trying to find out when that
george clooney um documentaries
which i cannot wait for right like um so
there he's there he's looking to really
see if they got a solid date for that
drop of that documentary that's really
going to put him in jeopardy but here's
a great another picture of these
boneheads where you see all the chairs
are empty there's three of them and like
you said the [ __ ] guy that took the
picture with his [ __ ] kids who's
encouraging the type of authoritarian
fascism that projects
these [ __ ] boneheads to go out and
kill people with these automatic weapons
guys the [ __ ] guy that shot up the
tulsa hospital bought the goddamn gun an
hour an hour before and let me tell you
something gabe about that
about this idea i i want i want to talk
about this for a second
seeing that eric's well well kind of
went on a rant here and jim jordan
is not paying attention the only one
that seems to be over there um not
looking at his phone is the old guy
thomas massey must be admiring the
pictures that he has in front of the
christmas tree with his children and
guns
this shooter in oklahoma in tulsa he
went into a gun store and bought that
gun that he murdered four people with
an hour before he went back to that
hospital now here's my argument and this
should be the right wing argument right
now this is obviously not what i believe
this is
on satire but this is what it sounds
like this is what these arguments from
these [ __ ] bone-headed knuckle
dragger should sound like
why in the hell did it take him
how can we expect to be free in this
country if it took a whole goddamn hour
a whole hour for him to get a gun can
you even imagine gabe if if in this
country you're free to own guns your
second amendment should not be impeded
his second amendment was impeded for
over an hour for over an hour this guy
had to wait before he went and murdered
someone with a gun that he's entitled to
his entitlement is that gun his
entitlement is to own that gun to
purchase that gun and to murder whoever
he wants to murder
the lack the lack of patriotism and
liberty and freedom that is in that hour
is absolutely ridiculous we we at
america first should fight for his
america's first right to go down to that
gun store and get that gun within
minutes within minutes so he can kill
that doctor
what are we doing here if we're not
making sure that people are armed to
kill doctors what are we doing what kind
of freedom do you want this is their
arguments folks this is what they sound
like this is what they sound like and
you have to throw this in their face
just like eric swalwell basically told
[ __ ] jim jordan get the [ __ ] out of
this room and head on down to texas and
go hail the killer go to tulsa go to
tulsa and [ __ ] give a goddamn eulogy
for the killer you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] because that's the freedom
that they want they want the freedom for
the killer they don't want the freedom
of the safety of your children they
don't want the freedom for you to send
your kids to school in a safe
environment they don't want the freedom
of you having choices over your body and
your uterus they don't want you having
the consent of your children of who they
can and can't marry and who they
identify as they want to diddle your
kids in ohio they want to [ __ ] feel
their genitalia if they get a whiff a
whiff that they're not the gender that
that they wanted to be during a [ __ ]
school game
i mean i said it yesterday
i was like you know it's crazy i don't
even know that bill was out there and i
you know i kind of joked about it
yesterday i was like as soon as those
people you know as soon as those kids go
into the bathroom they're going to be
lifting up the skirts and pulling down
pants
and then literally an hour later that
ohio bill is is is released and talked
about in the news i was like holy [ __ ] i
mean it was expected right we already
talked about people who wanted to marry
young kids we went to ban things from
schools we want to you know take away
rights oh it's the one person
that transition from
male to female and now everyone's
[ __ ] upset because that's the reason
that people transition
they're like oh well you know it's
because they want an advantage in sports
shut the [ __ ] up that is not
people think
that there's just like it's just like
overnight flip of the switch oh you know
what i'm a man and i want to be a woman
and i want to compete in sports and
that's the only reason because i want to
break records
do you know does anyone on that side
even know and i know this is rhetorical
but they do not understand the the
emotional physical
and just uh
intelligence that it takes for someone
to say
i don't feel comfortable in body and
this isn't who i was supposed to be and
i want to transition
and the amount of time that it takes
like they're just like oh yeah you know
what just take some hormones and then
you're good to go you know hey listen
it's not as quick as you could get a gun
okay it takes a much longer time
and there's a lot more at stake that you
have to deal with
and you want to take it away from people
but then you're like listen an hour
that's not that's not that's not short
enough we need to give you as soon as
you sign the papers should be able to
get that gun
so the ability that republicans look at
one thing and they say well this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] they want to do this
and i want to check out little kids i
want to like diddle with them and
whatever and then they're like oh yeah
well you know what we have no problem we
have no problem getting that gun to kill
the kids that we're trying to dittle and
make sure that they are you know what
they were born to be
or what they were born on the birth
certificate or whatever
they have no they have no care or or
actual compassion or empathy toward the
actual life of that child that they have
gone up in arms about
that they want to make sure that oh they
were born male or they're born female
they don't give a [ __ ]
they do not give a [ __ ]
especially when these children are
slaughtered in a school they go well
yep we're gonna find something else to
blame it
on oh you know what the distance between
this door was uh was two inches right uh
open and that's what it is that's what
it's got to be that's what it's got to
be it's always projection with these
folks just like we see peter navarro and
i'm not going to beat that that push
anymore peter navarro is apparently in
custody now for his his role in not only
contempt of congress but it seems like
under investigation from a grand jury
for obstruction of an official
proceeding which would be the
certification of the results he's
admitted as much on air and there's
plenty of video to play but i want to
get i want to get to um the alpha cuck
and the dishonorable mention uh i have
the alpha cuck here and let's do let's
do the alpha check first now elon musk
because you got a lot of i think that
you want to say about elon musk
you know i i i'm looking at the
dishonorable mention um graphic here
gabe can you load in our actual
dishonorable mention uh graphic there
why don't we talk about uh yeah yeah why
don't we talk about elon because i think
elon boy he's a special kind of [ __ ]
stupid didn't he yeah he sees something
all right well
this
it's it's trending this morning and i
think it's 10
of tesla or 10 tesla is what's trending
let's take a look here let's go to the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends here
now it was trending earlier tesla ten
percent of tesla and what he's wanting
to do is he's saying oh the economy is
going to be bad so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna i'm gonna fire and lay off ten
percent of the employees now you said
you said earlier
and this morning when we were texting
back and forth of who's going to be the
dishonorable mention and who's going to
be the alpha cuck um
you you really you had a few things that
you a few bones you wanted to pick with
elon
tell us tell us what bones you wanted to
pick with elon so
elon one of the things is that he wants
to cut 10 of the workforce now whether
that's an excuse because he's finding
that the company's losing money right
or whatever he wants to justify it as
you know because he's like oh [ __ ] i'm
not going to get this twitter deal
uh you know using that as an excuse to
say well actually we should remove 10
because they're not as efficient those
people don't actually want to work here
so i should just cut the fat now i say
that's complete [ __ ] that's just a
just a billionaire who wants to
uh cut corners
and wants to make more money
and wants to take advantage of
uh
of his of his control and his influence
and then blame it on the economy blame
it on buy it and blame it on inflation
you know he's been he's been touting
how how much he wants the economy to
crash and go into recession just the
other day well yeah and the reason he
wants this for many reasons and one of
the reasons i was talking about earlier
they really want to convince you
that that inflation is bad for you
because they don't want the because
they've inflated their wealth but now
we're to the point to where the workers
are like okay we need to inflate our
labor and once we get to the point the
national conversation becomes well let's
inflate the labor now now that all the
other profits are inflated
the business people like elon musk the
rich are like no no no no we need to go
into recession we need to go into
recession now we need to lay off workers
because here's here's what he here's
what he said um reuters has it here
exclusive tesla ceo um
soon to be not ceo probably elon musk
has a super bad feeling
he's he's gonna go off his gut here just
like he went off his gut with the
twitter deal right yeah like he went off
it come on
i i i i'll show you the [ __ ] picture
of him getting a haircut on his really
super bad feeling this is [ __ ] dumb a
super bad feeling about the economy and
wants to cut about 10 of jobs at the
electric car maker he said in an email
to executives seen by reuters now here's
here's my take on this this [ __ ]
idiot this isn't the haircut by the way
there's a different haircut that he you
should get a really
super bad feeling on about his haircut
that he had but here's what i'll tell
you gabe i think this is an attempt to
save his job as ceo oh yeah i think
that's what this is what he's what he's
signaling to the board is hey i can
actually make tesla money because he's
lost them so much money that he's
willing to spare 10 of the jobs 10 of
his workforce at tesla to make sure that
the board is reassured that he is in it
to make money not just to be a superstar
and i mean because the thing is you know
we're we're working toward the end of
the of q2
so he's got to show numbers right to say
hey actually
so he's thinking if i cut this workforce
here then that's the fastest way right
right exactly this way at the end at the
end of the day the board members want to
know is the company making money and am
i getting a return on my investment
right maybe some people care about the
you know the well-being of employees but
at the end of the day you put money in
and you're waiting to get the money back
or to make even more money and so when
they look at the end of q2 right
especially if his
his uh incentives tell the audience what
q2 is tell tell them what that means
what does that mean to not just tesla
but also elon and the board members in
the event right
q1 q2 q3 q4 that's the whole year split
into four quarters and that's typically
how a company will look and assess you
know
growth or
or if there was loss or gains or
whatever and they put out their earnings
every quarter right exactly and a lot of
times the stock or or or the investors
are in fact affected by whatever those
actual numbers that are made public
especially yeah exactly especially as a
public company you have to release these
things to your your investors the the
actual people who own stock the board
itself they have meetings before with
the board to say this is what we're
going to talk about this is how we want
to sugarcoat this this is how we want to
you know
finesse the numbers to make it seem like
it's not totally a bad thing
right so that you don't have
uh a a
um
a drop in confidence right because then
that obviously affects the stock price
because then investors say oh i don't
want to purchase or i want to sell this
this company instead
and so
when you've got you know four quarters
you know you've got 12 months three
months each so right now we've already
gone to q1 and q2
is we're coming through you know the end
of it was april may june
so he's got to make sure that by the end
of june he hits whatever the metrics are
or goes above them or he looks like he's
trying to do that right exactly because
he's got two because there's going to be
27 days
there's going to be projections if he
says i want to lay off 10 of the force
they're going to have to do internal
projections because they are a public
company they have to show you know what
what that would mean to the board
members and as him as being a ceo
because i think he's trying to save his
job here no yeah totally i mean he's
he's bullshitting he's using [ __ ]
just like he always does to try to save
his ass yeah i mean the end of the end
of q1 which is the end of march was
which is when this kind of really
started to go up in terms of this
twitter deal as a possibility
uh by like okay i've actually submitted
papers and whatnot but it was this past
quarter the past few months have been a
[ __ ] roller coaster which is like his
net worth is down tesla's value's down
you know uh and it seems to be of his
doing right right it is complete because
he he it was his passion project he
wanted to go off and purchase twitter
because he made him he made a joke the
right wing people said hey you should do
that he got stuck in a corner and felt
like he had to be that macho man and
actually do it and as a result he had to
actually [ __ ]
yeah he had he had to show his cards so
so what you're saying is he got cucked
and he got caught once he got the alpha
cuck but the other reason the other
reason that really pisses me off is that
not only is there's this ten percent but
he's also saying that people if they
want to keep their job
have to show up to the office now no
more work from home the minimum
to work
in the office is 40 hours
and he said and i cannot stress this
enough right whatever he said in his
little release that he made but
basically you have to show up to the
office now regardless of whatever state
the the health of the country or society
is you know especially especially as
we're you know dealing with covid but he
wants everyone a minimum of a minimum of
40 hours
quick question
when he did this did he do this like via
uh zoom did he did he release this no no
it wasn't oh i i just i thought i
thought maybe like he was doing a zoom
video from his mom's basement no no
telling everyone else they gotta go to
the [ __ ] office right now
that would be in typical
mom walks in the back you know she's
like oh honey did you see me on sports
illustrated and he's like not now right
um right i'm trying to tell everyone
that they have to do the opposite of
what i do exactly
he said a minimum
of 40 hours
which
as everyone knows the you know unless
you're doing over that it's overtime the
work week is 40 hours right so he's
trying to say you have to work in the
office at least 40 hours
or else
you're fired well but that's the thing
is we wouldn't have a 40-hour work week
without unions in this right right
without collective bargaining in this
country and so then he's trying to he's
trying to fend off collective bargaining
as well right exactly and that's why he
wants to move the texas to a right to
work state right and so i there's also
the uh i was reading very briefly about
it last night when this kind of dropped
but it's the uh
germany is now talking about how
that just you can't do that so i i don't
know what their role is in terms of
their labor and their employees but i
guess they're coming they're coming to
bat four employees of tesla who have
just been given this ultimatum which is
stay and come into the office and work
40 hours minimum or go and be unemployed
so it's not just it's not just he's
wanting to get rid of 10 of the
workforce he's actually trying to force
some of the workforce right out well
he's he's i mean he's got all these
facilities right and he has to make sure
that people get use out of them and he
has to make sure that they show up or
else they're just empty [ __ ]
you know abandoned areas so
it's not only you mean like his twitter
followers kind of right yeah yeah
whatever his uh whatever his fa i forget
what the ratio is but
13 million
oh yeah that's right it was 80 85
percent were real 15 were fake i think
it's like which is like double what it
in the normal is right yeah right
so
anyway there's a few reasons but those
two especially and it was the one where
the one that really pissed me off was
the you have to come into the office now
no more of this work from home [ __ ]
which is
insane because if you think about it
leading up to kind of this we'll say
revolution uh or this this movement that
we've had within the workforce of like
what is my value and what am i worth and
i want to unionize and actually get the
the rights that i should have
there was a belief by companies and my
company was the same way
um that believed that you you couldn't
actually do your job
without being in the office from nine to
five if your ass wasn't in the seat then
you weren't technically productive
they also believed that you had you
couldn't work from home because working
from home there are too many
distractions which is true because it's
[ __ ] real life and you've got kids
and you've got pets and you've got a
[ __ ] virus that you can't go into
public paces because of this
so
the the problem there was they said
if we have you work from home
the company is going to go to [ __ ]
but here's the problem what they soon
realized is they could get more hours
out of employees by working from home
because you get them up before nine and
after five so technically you're getting
above and beyond 40 hours for the pay
that you originally paying them for 40
hours in the actual office well and
they've shown they've shown that even
during those hours you're more
productive and the pandemic has proved a
lot of things yeah um not not not in
favor of corporations but in favor of
workers in the favor of labor and i
think that's what these these corporate
gouges are are terrified of um is is
like elon and some of these others
they're terrified that now we know what
our labor is worth we know how to we
should be able to collect a bargain for
it um and they're they're just they're
just there for pure profit and it seems
like they're you know
they're trying to bang up the worker
which that's exactly what they're doing
i want to i want to move on to the
dishonorable mention here
ron desantis
speaking of
botched coronavirus response
the other thing too is this guy [ __ ]
he is trying he is the blueprint for
manga nazis he is the blueprint for a
fascist state he is
he is laying out the groundwork gabe
of what they want to do to this country
i mean hook line sinker uh ron desantis
is he a manga nazi i don't know i would
say he probably is
i would say he probably i don't know
i don't know inquiring minds want to
know i'm just asking questions what is
this [ __ ] about the special olympics
first i i want because there's like a
thousand things we could drag this
[ __ ] through the mud for right
so from what i saw is the special
olympics wanted to compete and a
requirement was to get the vaccine
and then florida said
no no no
uh that isn't right you it goes against
your rights and then they said we just
want to [ __ ] play and then he made a
press conference which i did not see
but he did a press conference that
basically was like
the special olympics can't require us to
get a vaccine
well it's
here [ __ ] take this the scoop here
from jay o'brien is the state of florida
threatened the special olympics and now
if you guys don't know the special
olympics is the olympics that are held
the mentally challenged and with
two 27.5 million in fines so they want
to find them because the organization
had a vaccine requirement and its gains
in orlando this weekend so here's the
thing they go to orlando which he is
hell-bent on destroying orlando by the
way yeah like he wants to he's tearing
through that [ __ ] oh my god he [ __ ]
hates orlando because disney world is
there hell hath no fury like he even
sent this he even said well yeah exactly
he sent he sent his nazi supporters up
there to protest for him uh with nazi
flags i'm not making this [ __ ] up i i'm
when i say the let's go brandon nazis
and the ron desantis nazis i'm not
that's not that's not hyperbole he
literally
they're waving his supporters are waving
a nazi flag there they had banners that
said let's go brandon with nazi symbols
on them they are let's go brandon nazis
they are ron desantis nazis at disney
world protesting which is in orlando if
anyone's counting um but late yesterday
this special olympics pulled the
requirement so basically ron desantis is
using fascist tactics here to bully
private organizations that want to do
what they want to do do you remember
gabe when they used to [ __ ] [ __ ] and
moan about how uh they wouldn't let they
wouldn't let the government uh let
churches stay open you sons of [ __ ]
you sons of [ __ ] you're you're you're
you're not letting us stay open and blah
blah blah and on and on and the same
with businesses and restaurants and on
and on it [ __ ] went with this [ __ ]
about how democrats are trying to
control business and trying to control
organizations when all they were trying
to do is stop the spread of a [ __ ]
virus that's all they were trying to do
yeah crazy and here here they are here
they are
on the opposite end of the spectrum
trying to make sure the special olympics
is trying to make sure that people are
safe at their event by requiring a
vaccine and here he is
telling them they can't do that he's
doing the exact thing he said that he
did not want them to do and was against
your freedom it's a [ __ ] private
organization they are not part of the
florida government they're not part of
the us government they're a private
organization and these people are not
required to go to this event right
they're not working they dig it if they
said you want to go right
then right have have vaccination status
right like get the vaccine if you want
to attend it's right it's it sounds like
or watch it on tv whatever you want to
do you dummies so they have a choice
right to go or not go
and then you're coming in and saying
no
no one has a choice
you just have to
anyone can go
right and it's like well you know i'm
sorry but we made the rules yes we're in
florida but we made the rules
you can't over you can't over you can't
go in and [ __ ] reach for [ __ ]
like i thought you guys didn't want big
government
what happened to that i thought you guys
wanted a small government small armed
government
just little things here and there not
overreaching overbearing [ __ ]
grabbing your [ __ ] [ __ ] from other
people's plates on the dinner table
what happened to small government
speaking speaking of big government all
up in your [ __ ] [ __ ] here's another
story from the uh manga nazi um the
ron desantis the the donald trump
wannabe um this is an exclusive from nbc
news ron desantis administration asked
state medical board to ban transition
related care for minors and medicaid
recipients the two-prong effort ensures
desantis can act quickly without need
for legislative approval
i believe they're alluding to the fact
you know these these media
outlets don't write headlines like we do
gabe our headline is ron desantis a
manga nazi yeah let's get to the point
here guys that's right um but what
they're trying to get to here at the end
of their headline is can desantis act
quickly he's practicing to see how far
he can push this fascist state and so
far he's actually
ripping away people's health care right
yeah ripping away people's health care
for minors children and medicaid
recipients so poor people and and minors
children is he's ripping away their
medical care so
if you're wondering if you're wondering
why it seems like in florida there's a
blueprint for the fascist state that is
america first that that marjorie tater
green talks about the christian
nationalism here is your [ __ ]
evidence here's your evidence these
[ __ ] bigots are gonna come after your
children they're gonna come after your
[ __ ] health care they're gonna come
after rather you can be rather you can
choose to be even vaccinated right or a
private event can say hey we want to
make sure everyone's safe in our event
let's do that and they're banning math
um
for the profit of bookmakers christian
bookmakers i mean this is all
this is all just keeps perpetuating to i
mean also and and also remember that
none of those books had anything to do
with crt
well no
it said crt in the book it meant
something different but it said it in
the book yeah and we all we all know
that's what that means when you you know
you do that kind of thing now it's like
calculus right trigonometry you know
right now like that's a crt and it's
like
okay well the other the other uh story
because it doesn't end with ron desantis
here gabe no of course it doesn't no
never it never ends with one of them
right it's not just one story there well
no no i'm saying rhonda santa's
nazi there's another story oh of course
of course
you you see this uh desantis is creating
a special police force to let him pursue
voter fraud so so he's getting us
gazpacho a gazpacho police a floridan
fascist gazpacho police together
um so that way he has no federal
oversight so he can overturn elections
gabe it sounds like ron desantis is
really terrified that democrats are
going to win in florida i actually think
that's what they're scared of um
they see they see the state above them
georgia and they see the sea change that
is happening in georgia and i think they
they're terrified of this leaking into
the panhandle now the panhandle as we
know where matt gatz is elected in even
in south florida where they really have
uh used maga delusion to dilute uh
certain demographics that they are
should vote against their own interest
they're doing they're scared of up in
the panhandle that that's going to
happen too and also in central florida
where they have a lot of farming so
they're really terrified they're really
terrified that democrats are going to
win these elections um which would which
the problem with that they have in
florida and even in texas is the
narrative that they're read no matter
what right right that we're a red state
and really that is the actual thing that
they're [ __ ] terrified of is that
their narrative will be broken that
they're not actually a red state that
republicans don't rule and it's not
majority [ __ ] this nazi maga let's go
brandon nazi [ __ ] that florida wants
that floridians actually want some
democracy right they don't want to i
have i have yet and speaking of you know
voter suppression and just like
gerrymandering like i have yet to hear
an actual reason
for why these people try to redistrict
like obviously we know why right they're
gonna you know throw one area over here
and they have more and more more weight
toward a smaller population to make sure
that their vote goes further that their
party stays in power so on and so forth
i get it we all know why they're doing
it what i'm saying is i have not heard
an actual reason from them to justify
the decision
to gerrymander areas
so that smaller populations that are red
have more weight to their vote in the
overall
votes that come in
uh for that state right yet to hear that
have not heard it i never hear it
i you know nothing to do with it being
fair
if it was fair then you would just
equally wait everything right you cut up
your district to actual the bounds of
the area
and you would say that is your area
whether big or small but it's all
dependent on the actual region that you
you govern
but i've yet to hear an actual actual
real reason
from them
to say why they need to do it
i doubt you're going to hear any kind of
reality from these from these let's go
brandon nazis speaking of let's go
brandon nazis um
the other
let's go brandon nazi on our list was
louis gomer this guy is full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know the good news gabe this
[ __ ] tried to run for attorney general
in texas and ken paxton the guy who's
under federal indictment beat this dumb
[ __ ] yeah he beat louie gohmert
and but the good news is folks louis
gohmert won this week bone end of the
week this is our opponent of
the week so let's give him his do here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yay louie gomer
yay
you said it was kind of close with the
uh the votes yeah it i'm telling you
youtube flipped it on on twitter it was
close between peter navarro and uh louis
gomer but then on youtube it was way up
for louis gomer versus peter navarro so
it might be because this clip was
circulating around you it might it might
be i mean it was it was like 40 it was
probably like 40 something or 30
something 30 something or something like
that on twitter and then on youtube it
was like [ __ ] 70 for louie this may
this may have been why let's watch the
clip why louis ended up on bonehead of
the week
i i think back historically we had a
president in franklin roosevelt that on
d-day led the country in a six to eight
minute prayer
for our troops
and now we had a president come on after
uvalde
and he used god's name in vain most of
those would consider it was used as an
interjection not as a source from whom
to beg for wisdom like this country did
for most of our history
since the 60s we really started having
these mass shootings perhaps there was
something in the 60s maybe some supreme
court decisions that gave rise to people
being taught in school it's whatever you
think feels good
well it's time to get common sense he
thinks a lot of stuff feels good and i
think a lot of republicans think stuff
feels good so much so that they're
trying to pass laws where they can
inspect people's genitalia sporting
events jesus christ that's back and to
look historically about where people are
being murdered in record ranks and don't
repeat that like the democrat
this is not my feed by the way this is
his fee save lives i'm out of time
studio
so this is the the where he blamed
democrats and blamed it on the 60s right
now there is another clip that i want to
show here of louis gomer because it is
oh my god it is absolutely phenomenal um
if i can find it really quick here did
you see the one where he just absolutely
loses his [ __ ] mind i mean who's the
recent one oh he loses his mind he just
starts yelling about how how uh
the hearts and
the hearts and we don't have something
in our hearts and
uh here here it is here i believe uh
we'll play it here
people on the other side of the aisle
come in
and accuse republicans
of being complicit in murder yeah
because you are and that we put our
right to kill over
others right that's what i said that's
what i said that's what i said
to
infer by
rhetorical supposed questions who are
you here for
we must be here for the gunman yep you
are out yeah
it is an outrage it is a [ __ ] house
yeah how dare you how dare you you don't
have heart here it is yeah we don't it's
just that it's not that we don't think
it's that you don't yeah you literally
you haven't done nothing right there's
no proof that you do it all like show us
the proof that you do but you don't and
you know what you know what i find funny
is that you know whether the question is
actually prompted of them to be like do
you guys care or whatever might be on
the topic
they have this ability to ask the
question to be like you think we don't
care you think that we haven't done
anything you think like
it's the tucker carlson thing right
right right but it also reminds me of um
of the good liars from the nra where
they're actively saying like people
might say you know people say that you
did this or you didn't do that and you
did that and you when you when they're
talking to wayne lapierre exactly
yeah and so in this example this is
another moment where republicans
ask a question which obviously is
rhetorical because everyone knows what
the answer is right but they're like you
guys say that we don't care and we
haven't done anything and and we we
block you every time and it's like
yes yeah yes exactly yes like all these
things are yes you're answering yes to
every single question that you're asking
so thank you for projecting the
rhetorical questions
that now are on the record but you know
keep going let's watch the bone end of
the week lose his mind here this is
fantastic
when we look at the things that you're
doing and you're trying to do to america
we've seen the carnage
i mean for heaven's sake
let's take example
democrats control
the major cities that have the worst
murder rates
that's right
your ideas have been shown to get people
killed
is he gonna have an aneurysm
[Music]
in other words black people black people
that's what he's saying when he says
chicago and phil right like that's the
that's the that's the trope chica you
know chicago all that that quote-unquote
violence you know the the
the certain people on certain people
like right yeah it's just stop eating
around the bush just say it louis they
love to throw they love to throw my
hometown chicago in there which i like
you guys are [ __ ] dumb
what they don't understand is people
from chicago drive to gary indiana where
the [ __ ] laws are nothing to buy a
gun and they take them back into
illinois you dumb [ __ ] this
isn't this isn't rocket science and
louie gohmert having fake outrage about
about the black people in chicago
because and black people in philly
that's what he's saying
is is the same [ __ ] stupid fake
outrage of back doors that ted cruz had
right it's being done by democrats in
those big cities we care about people we
don't care about their lives no you
don't and lives have been so trivialized
we care deeply how dare you how dare you
you arrogant people
attributing murder
to those of us that want to do things to
stop it
no you don't get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you lying second [ __ ] that's why louie
gohmert is the bone in the league let's
give him his due we're running out of
time
[Music]
[Music]
and that is bone end of the week stick
around after the cute little song we
have a few announcements for you right
right right after the song
[Music]
[Applause]